Morning, Sheila.
- Morning, Sheila.
- Morning, boys.
Lindsay of Lindsay's
Mirror Depot called.
She wants to see the commercial.
- Well, that would make
three of us.
Shall we?
- Uh, one minute.
The third floor is...
calling my butthole's name.
- Is it, uh...
[high-pitched voice]
Oh, Frederick!
- [Southern accent]
Why, who is it?
- It's the third floor.
- Well, I declare,
I'm coming to poop on you.
[both giggling]
Actually, poop and pee.
I got to do both.
I--I'm talking as Sam now.
- I don't know
what you're doing.
- Yeah, no, it's me.
It's Sam.
- Oh. Well, if you're traveling,
you are going to need
your suitcase.
- Why, thank you,
my good man.
- Of course.
[exhales]
Did you get outside this
weekend, or did you...?
♪ ♪
- The phone lines are off,
so distribute the extension list
and Wi-Fi password.
Also, make sure everybody
breaks down their empty
cardboard boxes for recycling.
[eerie music]
[high-pitched tone]
- [heavy breathing]
Tim. It's over.
It's over.
The third floor is over.
- Sam, slow down.
What are you talking about?
- [stammering]
So okay, so I went downstairs
to poop, and then, uh--
you--I went downstairs.
There's a bunch of people,
and there's--there's
a business down there, and--
- You sped up.
You sped up.
- [stammering] A password--
- Sam, slow down.
What's wrong?
- We can't poop on
the third floor anymore.
- Take it back.
What the hell?
- [choking]
- Take it back.
[both struggling]
- Stop trying to kill me.
- You're frickin' stronger
than me.
Who cares?
[suspenseful music]
♪ ♪